hello so with this recording i'd like to
introduce a topic of flavor symmetry
what do we mean by that so when the
neutron was discovered
it was noted that the mass of the
neutron is very close to the mass of the
proton
and so it seems like those two particles
are somehow related even so the electric
charge
is different the proton charged the
neutron is neutral
and you can see here that the masses are
really very very close
about 1 mb or 1 different in mars
so heisenberg proposed and that was in
the 1930s
to regard them as two states of the same
particle
they were really so different that you
could you know think that they are
basically the same
just you know a rotation from one into
the other
and that's exactly what he did um
considering them as one
particle a nucleon nucleon um where the
proton
you know is um described as a duplet
with you know an up to plate and the
neutron
has a down loopbed similar to you know
an up quark and a down quark an electron
in neutrino
later on those particles were not known
at the time
so he introduces a new concept so-called
isospin
or strong isospin where he's doing
exactly this he labels the proton up
and he labels the neutron down so so far
we haven't done anything but
you know introduced new neighbor labels
for new part four for particles new
particles of the time
but now if you assume that the strong
force is invariant
under rotations in this isospin space
meaning
you know when you flip the neutron into
a proton and vice versa
those rotations are invariant uh the
strong forces invariant under those
rotations
um that means or it follows directly
that the isospin is conserved
in all strong interactions so that is
what really the conclusion is of this
introduction of those new labels
is that isospin is conserved under
strong interactions
so this was proposed in the 1930s again
you know we noticed this symmetry in
nature and from that symmetry a
conservation of um follows
even so and we can conclude uh
you know physics um cross-sections or
ratios of cross-sections from it
without understanding in this case qcd
is from interaction
this is quite very fascinating and you
can
just apply this concept now to other
particles for example the pion
the pion has an isospin or one and there
are three pions or three states
the zero state the upstate and the down
states which is
pi plus the pi zero and the y minus
um in general you can conclude that the
multiplicity of your particles
um you know as you see the neutron of
the proton the pipe cluster pi zero and
minus um the multiplicity is two times
the isospin plus one isospin equal one
means that the three particles
as part of the representation
so far so good so later
you know this this concept was you know
moved to other
new particles many new particles were
introduced and produced
in the emergent accelerators and
experiments on the market and people
tried to classify them in those
um by their by their isospin
gelman and nishiyama empirically
observed that there is a relation with
schwarz this equation here
which is that the charge if you assign
the maximum value i3
the third component of your isospin to
the member of the multiplet
is the highest charged in the previous
example was either the proton
or the pi plus then the charge of this
particle follows from the isospin
the barrier number and the strangeness
we looked at barrio number and strangers
before with as a reminder
strangeness is the number of strange
quarks in
in the barrier of the mason and the
buyer number is simply the number of
variants
so if you just look at this as for
example for this pion case
we had the isospin equal one
bio number equals zeros changes zero
which follows that the maximum charge
involved is one
which is the charge of the positively
charged power
so fast because this was impurity
observed
but once you then later discover
and develop a chord model this is set in
the 1970s
um you can reduce this equation directly
from the assignment of
isospin to quarks which is rather
fascinating again
you don't understand the physics fully
but just from the symmetry you can and
empirically you can deduce
information about physical systems
however
if you try to now extend
this idea of either spin to a complete
to the complete crop model you find we
find that
the symmetry starts to be broken it
already starts to be broken slightly
when you
include strangeness or strange quarks
but it's badly broken when you include
charm bottom on top and the reason can
be seen here
the up quark and the down quark both of
the particles making up
ions and the neutron and the proton
and even if you include strain the
difference in mass
is not very large so you know the
symmetry the particles
you know really look like they're the
same
particle in a different state of the
same particle well when you introduce
other quarks heavier clocks charm on
bottom
you find that the mass differences are
so large that the symmetries are
programmed so this concept starts
failing
because of the large mass differences
because the symmetry
is broken all right so from here
we now go to discrete symmetries
and again from the obser observation of
those symmetries you can reduce
physics without fully understanding the
underlyings
you